all right so all of the methods that
we've just shown right 1a 1b 1c they
relied on proving that this um
imaginary axis is tangent okay so is
there a way to do this else you know
without relying on that fact the answer
is definitely yes okay so i'm going to
um pull over into desmos for a second i
hope the thing i drew before is going to
still be there
i'm going to use the fact that if we go
back to part one
we showed that this angle up here is pi
on three right
and pi on three 60 degrees is handy
because it's the angle in
it's one of the angles in an equilateral
triangle in fact all the angles in an
equilateral triangle are pi on three and
remember z is it can move all the way
along this major arc so what i can do is
i can move z somewhere else to form a a
triangle a b z that is
equilateral and equilateral triangles
are so nice like things are equal um
you've got perpendicular bisectors the
logic just falls out very neatly because
you've made things nice and simple
you've you've gained symmetry and
symmetry can be used to make a whole
bunch of different arguments that are
very convenient okay
so that's what i'm going to do so follow
along with me so
what we're looking at here here is a
representation of what we had before but
what i want you to notice is that point
up there um i think it's it's z is the
movable point right we can reposition it
so that if i move it over i'll move s
like that
if i move it over to here you can see oh
oopsie does it let's try and go whoops
so uncoordinated i've got stubby fingers
uh that'll just have to do you can see
that looks pretty equilateral right it's
still pi on three up there in the corner
but what it creates is an additional pi
on three in the bottom in the left hand
side and in the bottom right hand side
okay
and so what i can do is i can create a
new diagram
that has an equilateral triangle in it
rather than the original weirdo sideways
triangle
and from there i can reason okay i want
to find out what that point is where
that particular z is and then i can do
some reasoning from there okay so let's
come back to our original diagram this
is what things look like now
okay
you can see what i've created is um this
equilateral triangle here so i'm going
to call that a b
p
and then in order to find where p is
because i'm saying that this thing is
equilateral right what that means is all
of the lengths of the sides are equal
equilateral so a way that i can find it
is by saying if this length here a b
is 4
then bp will also be 4 and ap will also
be 4. so a way that i can determine the
location of that point is by saying if i
have a circle centered at b
with the appropriate radius right
which is four in this case and i have
another center sorry another circle
centered at a which also has the same
radius right so this is a radius of four
then at the point where they intersect
um you're going to have a distance of
four here a distance of four here we
already know that a b is four that
creates the equilateral triangle so i
want you to take a moment have a think
for a minute i'm going to ask you to
write this on your own page it's a bit
awkward to type so i won't make you do
it but i'm going to give you 30 seconds
to think what are the equations of these
two dotted gray circles that i'm talking
about right i know where the center is
i've said i want to have a radius of 4
here and here to create this equilateral
triangle so what will the equations of
these two circles be because then i can
solve them simultaneously and find out
where p is supposed to be
take a moment have a think
you know the center
you know the radius
the radius radii are the same actually
so i hope you came up with something a
bit like this right
this down here
this one is x minus 2 3. so it's
centered at b you see that uh and it's y
squared because i haven't moved anywhere
vertically and then you've just got r
squared on the right hand side which
we've already determined is going to be
4 squared so there's circle 1 i'll just
label that as such this is circle one
and then you've got circle two over here
and i've not moved horizontally you can
see it's on the imaginary axis i've
moved up two units so that's why i'm y
minus two all squared and then the same
radius you can see there on the right
hand side i'm going to say they
intersect at p and i'm up here in the
first quadrant so you can see i'm just
going to say i'm going to restrict x and
y to both being positive okay
now from here what i need to do i'm
trying to find where that point p is
it's the particular z that gives me an
equilateral triangle so all i need to do
is solve simultaneously i know it looks
like it's going to be a mess because
you're like uh gross all of this stuff
to expand but because your circles are
so alike
you're going to get x squareds and y
squareds cancelling right and you can
see them there highlighted in red and
purple down below so once they cancel
you end up with a linear equation
because you've just got some constants
you've got some x's and y's but no x
squareds and no y squareds right
so that eventually lands you here
now i just want you to look at this for
a moment y equals square root of three x
minus two remember what we're trying to
do it was i'm trying to find where that
point p is up there but surprisingly i
have not found out the coordinates of
anything an x equals and a y equals in
fact i've found a line
what is that lined and the answer is
it's actually um where
the two points of intersection are think
about this right if you've got two
circles
like this his second one his circle two
there is not just one point p where the
two circles intersect you could say is a
p one
and a p
two where they intersect and what we've
found is the line along which p1 and p2
sit it's going to be this line in here
okay
so essentially what we've got i'll put
in here is a line that looks think about
this right it's root 3x so think about
the gradient and then it's minus 2. i've
actually already worked this out so i
know it's going to be this line here and
if i wrapped around this circle all the
way over here you'd find another point
of intersection somewhere down here okay
i can't actually show you the full
circles because this diagram that
they've given us is so off scale that my
circles are too scale and so you
actually would get a misleading and
misleading answer if i showed you them
the full theme but don't worry i'll come
back to desmos to show you what the
diagram really should look like okay
so what do i do with this i want to find
a single point p not a p one and a p two
so all i need to do is take that and um
substitute it back into the equation to
find um some appropriate values so long
as i've got my restriction right for x
and y being greater than zero so here's
the way that i've unfolded it
i want to pick an equation that's easy
to go back into so either one or two
one has some grossers in it so i'm going
to put it straight back into two
you can see that that gives me this
so i've just substituted you can see
there's the x squared and here's the y
right there minus 2 all squared so
that's where
that result just flops into there so you
can follow that right there
okay and from here you can see i'm just
going to get a quadratic in x even
before you expand things out once you've
got that quadratic in x it'll have the
two solutions which represent p1 and p2
and then we can find which is the
appropriate one by using the
restrictions that i placed on x and y
earlier namely that they have to be both
positive to get this thing up in the
first quadrant okay
so once you go ahead and solve that like
i said you end up with this quadratic
i've just sort of simplified here this
all expands
you get this which
you can see it's because these constant
terms are just going to cancel out with
each other and then from there you get
this you can you know divide through
simplify things and then i'm about to
factorize or i have rather factorized
here okay now owing to my restriction
that x has to be positive one of the
solutions out of here is x equals zero
but i'm not interested in that this
point p that i've joined here clearly
doesn't have an x value a real value a
real component i should say a real part
of zero it's over here in the first
quadrant so therefore i can exclude it i
can say hey x is greater than 0 you can
disregard that x equals 0 solution so
that just gives me x equals 2 root 3
only
so what does that tell you 2 root 3 well
that tells you that this thing here
is two root three units horizontally
moved over okay
i can use that x equals 2 3 to then find
y
because i just substitute that into i
guess this equation up here put in the 2
root 3 there and it simplifies out very
easily
2 root 3 times root 3 is just equal to
6.
so you get 4 so p is at this point up
here 2 3 plus 4 i so let me just put
that back on my diagram
2 root 3 plus 4i okay
now you'll say mr wu great we've just
shown we have this equilateral triangle
and i've found the points of it i know
where these other points are as well so
that's great but what do i do with this
there's a bunch of different things you
could do but my favorite way is taking
advantage of a really nice geometric
property that actually relates to
physics right
i'm trying to find the center of the
circle that's the whole point of this
question but because i've inscribed an
equilateral triangle in inside this
circle
um the center of the circle will be the
same as the center of the triangle right
now when i say center there are actually
very diff a variety different ways to
talk about the center of the triangle in
the same way as when you talk about the
center of a data set you could say oh do
you mean the mean or the median or the
mode
even when i say mean it's like do you
mean the arithmetic mean or the
geometric mean or the harmonic mean
that's a bit sneaky the harmonic means
not in the syllabus so if you're like
mister we've never heard of that before
don't worry you can look it up though
it's quite cool
the question that you have to ask is
which center is actually relevant
and it's going to be this center right
here which is actually the the center of
mass of the um of this triangle here um
it looks a little bit of skew because
this their diagram is not very good but
i've got a more fixed-up diagram which
you'll see in a second
if you're a physics student you might
call the center of mass the baro center
but in mathematics we would call this
the centroid
the centroid of a triangle
can just be found by averaging out the
coordinates of the three vertices and
once you do that bam the center is done
an arithmetic mean is very easy to
calculate excuse me once you have all of
these coordinates which we've just
determined okay
so how do we find the centroid let's
just follow the logic here the center of
the circle is at the centroid that's
what i just stated and if you were
reasoning through you'd have to include
that in your proof
and i can find the coordinates by taking
that arithmetic mean so the arithmetic
mean is just add them all up and then
divide right so you can see here i'm
going to do that for the x-coordinates
so i know the x-coordinates are going to
be
0 here this is 2 root 3 and you can see
i found that this is 2 root 3 and you
can see how bad the diagram is like this
should actually be vertically above one
one another but they're not because the
diagram is askew so i'll show you on my
fixed diagram what it should look like
so i've got 0 2 root 3 and 2 root 3. i
add them up and i divide by
3 and as you can see that's a familiar
number because we already know what the
coordinates of the center are
you do the same thing for y so you're
going to have
2i 0 and 4i right 4i is the y the
imaginary part of the number we just
found
you're going to get 6i in here you
divide by 3 and get 2i so bam there's
the center and because you know we
reasoned earlier that you're going to be
horizontally across i can say by
comparing
with the coordinates of a
this is going to be just horizontally
displaced i didn't have to prove
anything to do with the tangent i've
just found these coordinates by virtue
of this other reasoning that had nothing
to do with the tangent it just had to do
with this equilateral triangle so that
gives you the radius because you're off
by that distance from 2i
okay
so i said that i would show you a proper
diagram this is a proper diagram this is
actually to scale so you can see here
there is point p which we found at
2 root 3 plus 4 i and that's why it is
vertically above this original point b
which is a 2 root 3
and of course you've got a which is here
at 2 i so you can see it's it's it's
much taller actually than the original
diagram they provided us and that's why
things are kind of were skewed on their
version and there's the center of the
centroid as we just found